you
I need some help gramma
I need $600 634 watch I'm pregnant
who is he a one-night stand oh you know
he's kind of my boyfriend yeah why
didn't you use a condom or for
Humanity's sake get a vasectomy
who is this looks like Emily you know I
cut my credit cards up into little
pieces
I made a wind chime out of them why
would you do that why are you selling
those but I need some cash I need $500
you must not have a lot of friends now
you need me and I'm broke you want to
tattoo a little one not that I can do
listen grandma you better watch yourself
give us the money get out of my home
crazy old Oh you know I liked your
boyfriend he's special
really charismatic you know you need to
be able to say screw you sometimes I
sister you oh you didn't say screw you
to have that little creep back there I'm
sorry but I'm gonna have to ask you to
leave you're disturbing the customers I
mean what other customers are we
disturbing oh damn Ozzie and Harriet
and all coffee drips you don't have to
say drip coffee that is a redundancy old
oh my god it drips I'm scared I'm scared
of your mom since she was five years old
I mean any idiot could see that you need
to be supervised am i right are you
saying I'm any idiot what is this
what is the feminine mystique listed to
character in Xmen what
guess I'm an idiot yes you are screw you
grandma
not bad what is your involvement I am
her grandmother and I'm your mother
yes but what are you doing here I'm
gonna be there because this is my
granddaughter
she's already pregnant prema
you